do you understand you were part of the
AF is directing workshop for women yes
where were you in your life when you
first walked in those doors um I had
been an actress for about 12 years and I
had had a moderate moderately successful
career but at some point it was not
satisfying to me artistically because
the kind of roles the work that I was
doing was never anything that
artistically satisfied me except some
stuff that I did in the theater and one
day of a friend of mine called me up I
was on a woman's committee at the screen
actors guild and another woman on the
committee called me up and said that her
husband was doing a film shoot and
needed an assistant and did I know
anybody because I had a young son at the
time she thought maybe my son would want
to be an assistant and she said you did
I know anybody who would want to be a
production assistant and I said yes me
and she said you I said yeah I want to
try getting on the other side of the
camera to see what's going on there so I
took that job and they hired me to be a
production assistant for this commercial
company and at that time I said this is
where I want to be I don't want to be on
the other side of the camera this is
where I feel creative I feel energetic I
love what I'm doing I feel like myself
and at that time the AFI had just
started to do the directing workshop for
women and another friend of mine was
doing a project there she had been
accepted into the workshop Lenore
DeKoven and she needed an assistant to
help on her fill and I said oh yeah I'd
like to do that so I helped her get her
film made and once I was done with that
I said oh this is great I want to be in
this program and at that time they were
taking my mainly people who were already
successful in the industry women who had
writing careers or wed
rected on Broadway or who were stars
they had a lot of well-known actresses
and bancroft and joanne woodward and
people like that were in the program but
i applied to the program and i didn't
get in but what I got was on the wait
list in case somebody dropped out there
were like three of us on the waitlist
and about three months into the program
somebody dropped out a writer dropped
out of the program and they called me
and said judy you want to be in the
program you're in and I think this is
this is it Here I am and so that's how I
got into the program what were some of
the basic things they taught you ever
that AFI has a very distinct style why I
could be wrong I was just a couple
things I've read but what were some of
the things that they taught you and that
were different maybe from other places
that you at that point there was very
little instruction what you did was
spend a day with a technician who taught
you how to plug in all your equipment
who taught you how to run an editing
system and at that time we were editing
in 1-inch large editing and I had I have
done a radio show before and so I had
edited tape before I had edited the
little quarter-inch audio tape and I was
pretty skilled at it so when we got to
editing the one inch tape that was great
i love that and i would never forget he
gave us instruction and he said just
think of electronics as electronic
plumbing you plug a thing in here the
current goes in there you plug it in
there the current goes there it's just
like water running through pipes and for
some reason that weird description
served me great it really made me
understand that it was nothing
mysterious that it was very simple and I
just seemed to have an affinity for it
and that was basically all the
instruction we got then after that they
gave you the equipment they gave you a
small amount
money and they gave you access to
everything at AFI and you went out and
made you feel and it was you know they
threw you out out of the nest and you
flew or you didn't but fortunately I
flew does he have any type of guide come
with you um we know you knew learn how
to use it and you got yourself a
producer who you worked with and you
struggled you made mistakes and and and
you did it right and you did it wrong
and you were free to do whatever you
wanted it may be different now I think
now there's a lot more guidance goes on
I know there's a whole intense month
that the women put in with classes and
trainings my associate producer aaron
lee is now in the program and I know
she's just come through a really
intensive month of training but the
difference in the program now is they
don't give you any money they make you
go out and raise your money I think I
Kickstarter so you know the world has
changed for the better and for the worse
what time period uh we're looking at
from the moment it you started what's
the waitlist you know what time period
oh yes in the in the program in the
program it's a year oh it's a year
program because they bring in a whole
new group every year so you have a year
in the program to do whatever you're
gonna do and this is a short film short
film yes right and they let you choose
any genre yeah yeah I think we did
submit scripts and gotta go ahead or yay
or a nay depending on whether they
thought it we were thinking too out of
the box or you know crazy stuff that
couldn't possibly be done but mine got
approved and I shot a short film and
then do they have a screening yes fans
greening they have a screening every
year of all the films of all the women
that are in the program and it's a it's
wonderful to see how many women are
getting a shot because one of the things
about being a filmmaker is you have to
practice you have to practice your
skills and it's not you know like
picking up a guitar and you sit in a
room by
self you you need a whole crew you need
equipment you need money you need and
sometimes I would say to myself am I
crazy what am I doing here but if you're
driven you can't help it you're crazy
anyway do you remember some of the first
days that when you sort of quote out of
the nest with the camera so the things
that happened just being out there not
quite sure how many people on your crew
but just some of the things that happen
oh I do remember shooting one day that
was like I think a 19-hour day where I
just practically killed my crew and for
some reason I was so wired I didn't even
know how long it was taking or what time
it was there anything I just knew I had
a limited amount of time in a limited
amount of days and you're really gorilla
shooting the whole time and at the end
of it I thought wow that's not something
I really want to be doing to accrue now
this happens on feature films all the
time but it's not good and you know in
Europe they're very civilized they break
like at six o'clock and they come back
the next morning they empty and you know
but here it's like work I wasn't crazy
about doing that
you